the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another game of THS Z A
Song of Ice and Fire update video in
this video I'll be discussing George R
Martin's official announcements about
House of the dragon and the Winds of
Winter all of these new updates will
have a lot of fans very excited this
might be the last one we get this year
now as you all know George R Martin has
been writing the Winds of Winter for
over a decade this is something I've
discussed in many different videos over
the years according to George R Martin
this has been his number one Focus since
he stopped writing episodes for Game of
Thrones after season 4 and it's no
secret the novel is very late George R
Martin has missed so many deadlines
there's many fans who believe it will
never release I'll even admit that
there's day when I believe the same
thing as soon as he gives an update that
sounds like he's nearly done he always
follows that up with another update that
makes us think he's still years away
from ever getting it finished well he
wrote something on his not blog this
morning that I think some of you will
find very interesting while George R
Martin has been over in Europe for the
last few weeks he said he found time to
go meet with his British Publishers to
discuss the wild cards A Song of Ice and
Fire and of course the ones of winter
although this might not mean anything I
can't help but be excited by the thought
of them discussing its release
I sure they're wanting to know exactly
how much he has done and when he thinks
he will finally have an official release
date I would actually not be shocked if
they decide they will need to divide the
novels into halves like they did With A
Feast for Crows and A Dance with Dragons
based on George R Martin's recent update
he said he's written over 1100 pages so
far one day they might just decide it's
best if he releases what he already has
done since they've been waiting for over
a decade as well now I know this is
wishful thinking but I want to believe
he gave us this information for a good
reason let me know your thoughts down
below he also gave us a very exciting
update about House of the Dragon he said
I also spent three days with House of
the Dragon starting with a visit to the
studio where House of the Dragon is
being shot I had originally wanted to
visit there months ago but the wga
strike ended that and instead I stayed
here in Santa Fe working on Winds of
Winter all I have to say about that is
oh my God now I'm no stranger to film
sets I've worked of and on in television
and film since 1986 where I joined the
staff of the light zone Revival at CBS I
still recall the rush where I saw them
building Stonehenge on the Sound Stage
behind my office for an episode I'd
written and of course I visited the Game
of Thrones shoots in Belfast Scotland
Morocco and Malta those were incredible
too but nothing I have ever seen can't
compare with the red keep and dragon
Stone sets they've built at leaves in
studios in London they're massive
stunning and so damn real that I felt as
if I'd gone through a time portal to a
medieval Westeros I love castles and
have visited dozen of actual medieval
castles keeps and Towers in my time and
none of the real castles I've ever seen
can hold a candle to a red keep that
just goes to show you how successful
Game of Thrones actually was how of the
dragon's very first season has a budget
large enough to make it look like and
feel like Game of Thrones did at the end
when it was a worldwide phenomenon now
as fun as that was it was not all
tromping through the sets though I also
spent a few days locked in a room with
Ryan Condell and his writing staff
talking about the third and fourth
seasons of House of the Dragon they were
Lively fun discussions and we got some
good work done though 2 days was not
nearly enough there's so much ground to
cover that I'm not sure 20 days would
have been enough either it's also
exciting to know they're already
discussing the third and four seasons of
House of the Dragon I hope George or
Martin was able to give them enough
insight into where the series should
actually go in the end now most of you
already know how it ends if you've read
Fire and Blood but I'm hoping he gave
them some great ideas on how they should
get there we don't want House of the
Dragon to end on a very sour note like
Game of Thrones did however I don't
believe that is likely because it should
be incredible as long as they follow his
guideline he ends his not a Blog by
adding the highlight of the trypto had
to be the sneak preview that Ryan gave
me of the first two episodes of House of
the Dragon second season now keep in
mind the first two episodes he was shown
were unfinished versions they most
likely didn't have all these special
effects already added then he says I'm
hardly objective when talking about
anything based on my own work but I have
to say I thought both episodes were
great and they're not even finished yet
now they are dark mind you they're
actually very dark they might make you
want to cry I did not cry myself but one
of my friends did these first two
episodes were very powerful emotional
gut-wrenching and heart-rending exactly
the sort of thing I like now what can I
say I was weaned on Shakespeare and love
the tragedies and history plays best of
all but now I'm back home and there's
much work to be done well there you have
it ladies and gentlemen George R Martin
had a very interesting holiday while
over in Europe not not only did he meet
with his British Publishers to discuss a
song of L and fire and Winds of Winter
but he also met with House of the
Dragons writers to discuss the ending of
the show it seems we may only be getting
four seasons of House of the Dragon but
have no fear because the adventures of
Duncan egg will begin filming within the
next six months not to mention George R
Martin also recently announced he's
working on eight different Game of
Thrones shows with HBO so even if House
of the Dragon ends and the Winds of
Winter doesn't release I believe will'll
still be in Westeros one way or another
any project George different projects
well yes I mean of course we have the
new in television we have the new show
House of the Dragon which has just
finished filming his second season and
we're going to be doing planning for the
third season soon but I also have like
eight other spin-off shows that we're
you know we're developing uh the Duncan
egg show has been green lit um the
others not yet but we're still working
on them developing some of them make do
the main thing I'm actually writing of
course is the the same thing I wish I
could write as fast as Bernard but I'm
12 years late on this damn novel uh and
I'm struggling with it you know I have
like 1100 Pages written but I still have
100 more pages to to go it's a big
mother of a of a book um for whatever
reason maybe I should have started
writing smaller books when I began this
but uh it's it's tough but that's the
main thing that dominates most my
working life is is that okay we'll wait
we'll wait when it's ready it's ready
hopefully HBO will give us their own
official announcement about that very
soon now before you go let me know what
you think about George R Martin's new
updates down below as always I want to
thank all of you for watching another
video I will be making new ones every
week until House of the Dragons new
season releases this summer I hope I'll
see all you back here for those as well
have a great day everyone I'll see you
soon
bye
[Music]
e